[Musique]
de même
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouvez
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi pour
décrypter les grands titres de
l'actualité au sommaire de ce lundi 7
février
émission spéciale ce soir consacrée au
dossier ukrainien rencontre aujourd'hui
en ce moment même entre vladimir poutine
emmanuel macron après plusieurs heures
en tête à tête presque quatre heures le
président russe et son homologue
français vont tenir dans quelques
instants une conférence de presse
commune à suivre en direct sur rt france
quels sont les enjeux à quoi doit-on
s'attendre
nous serons direct avec nos équipes à
moscou et paris et avec nos invités en
plateau pour le décryptage au delà des
discours politiques qu'en est il des
populations sur place comment vivent
tels cette crise l'ukrainienne nous
recevons sur ce plateau notamment jérôme
sessini photographe membre de magnum
photos lauréat du world press photo il a
passé plusieurs années en ukraine
notamment pendant la guerre il viendra
vous apporté son précieux témoignage
à 21h quelles répercussions politiques
de ce voyage aurait valu l macron le
président français pas encore
officiellement candidat pris un risque
diplomatique mais entend sans doute
capitaliser sur un éventuel succès alors
comment est perçu son initiative sur la
scène politique française quels en sont
les risques mais aussi les éventuels
bénéfices on en débattra avec nos
invités et nos analyses sur ce plateau
[Musique]
édition spéciale donc consacré à la
crise ukrainienne vladimir poutine
reçoit en ce moment même emmanuel macron
à moscou déplacement du président
français qui veut avancer vers une
désescalade dans ce conflit aux portes
de l'europe on en parle tout de suite
avec notre correspondant à moscou
antoine claireaux bonsoir antoine les
deux hommes sont maintenant ensemble
depuis presque quatre heures et on
attend d'un instant à l'autre une
conférence de presse commune
oui tout à fait même si au moment où je
vous parle les journalistes se trouvent
toujours en salle de presse ils n'ont
toujours pas été convié dans la salle où
la conférence de presse va se tenir
autant dire que ce n'est pas encore
exactement pour tout de suite alors pour
information des plateaux repas ont été
apportés aux deux présidents il continue
donc leurs négociations à l'heure
actuelle et bien à table j'aimerais
maintenant revenir sur les seules images
que nous avons eues pour le moment à
savoir le protocole d'accueil le moment
où vladimir poutine a accueilli son
homologue français le président russe a
dit se réjouir d'accueillir emmanuel
macron au kremlin l'occasion de pouvoir
discuter de toutes les problématiques du
moment particulier l'ukraine bien
entendu et ce en profondeur et dans un
format plus personnel que lors des
différentes conversations téléphoniques
qui ont eu lieu jusque maintenant le
président russe a également rappelé à
son homologue qu'il n'était pas le
premier président français à se frotter
à la question ukrainienne écoutez je
vois aussi que les autorités présentes
le président français
appliqué de gros efforts pour régler la
crise relative à la sécurité européenne
pour la perspective historique cela
concerne également les sujets relatifs
au règlement de la crise entre
ukrainienne à l'est du pays
durant nos échanges téléphoniques nous
avons abordé en détail
c'est
ce pays je sais que toi tu as sa vision
et je suis vraiment heureux d'avoir
l'opportunité de te voir en direct et en
présentiel soient bienvenues
le président russe a fait savoir que la
france était en effet impliqué dans la
résolution de nombreuses problématiques
fondamentales liées à la sécurité
européenne en témoignent les récentes
les récentes conversations téléphoniques
qu'il a eus vis-à-vis de son homologue
français sur le dossier de l'ukraine ont
phase manuelle macron avec un visage
plutôt fermée lors de ce protocole
d'accueil et l'avocat une situation
critique en europe au niveau sécuritaire
il a également ajouté qu'il était bien
décidé en compagnie de ses alliés deux
européens mais aussi de l'otan à tendre
vers la désescalade écoutez
ce dialogue est nécessaire car c'est le
seul qui permet à mes yeux de bâtir une
vraie sécurité stabilité pour le
continent européen c'est pourquoi
contexte actuel nous avons eu ces
dernières semaines plusieurs échanges
téléphoniques dû le rappeler et tous ces
derniers mois au demeurant malgré la
crise j'ai pu aussi échangé avec le
président aziz qui pour ce qui est de
l'ukraine mais mes coordonnées avec
de nombreux européens et alliés
qu'il s'agisse aussi des britanniques ou
des américains des canadiens et je pense
que la discussion d'aujourd'hui à mes
yeux
amorcé une
ce vers quoi nous devons aller qui est
une une désescalade dont nous
connaissons d'ailleurs les termes la
situation politico-militaire
la question ne craignait non il rappelle
l'importance et le format normandie la
situation sécuritaire en biélorussie et
dans toute la région
et les grandes questions évidemment de
sécurité collective dont nous allons
parler
cela fait maintenant plus de 3h30 que
les deux hommes discutent derrière
portes closes et tous attendent ici
désormais qu'on nous guide vers la salle
de conférence de presse afin que les
deux hommes nous livre le résultat de
leurs négociations aux armes est
peut-être encore de patience tout comme
nous d'ailleurs merci antoine clé en
direct de moscou et une rencontre donc
entre eux emmanuel macron et vladimir
poutine jugée importante par le kremlin
mais ce n'est pas le premier face à face
on en parle avec notre reporter n'est
déjà des razak bonsoir nadège c'est donc
la troisième rencontre entre les deux
hommes déplacement à à forts enjeux
européens également nadège évidemment
l'europe vit le moment le plus dangereux
pour sa sécurité depuis la fin de la
guerre froide ces mots plus
qu'alarmistes sont signés de joseph
bourrel le chef de la diplomatie
européenne estime qu'une solution
diplomatique à la crise ukrainienne est
envisagée mais menace de représailles en
cas de passage à l'acte à des russes en
ukraine
nous pensons qu'une solution
diplomatique à cette crise est toujours
possible nous espérons le meilleur mais
nous nous préparons au pire
et quels sont les enjeux de ce
déplacement à des manuels mais cros
nadège alors cette crise internationale
sur le dossier ukrainien il bouleverse l
agenda à des manuels macron et cela à
deux mois de l'élection présidentielle
celui qui rechignent à annoncer sa
candidature candidature dont personne ne
doute a décidé de se mobiliser dans ce
dossier hautement explosif emmanuel
macron endosse le rôle de leader dans
cette crise ukrainienne et il coordonne
la position occidentale avec vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron a tout essayé et
versailles brégançon et un nombre
incalculable d'appels téléphoniques
alors à chaque fois il n'a pas obtenu
grand chose mais il persévère pourquoi
et bien parce que l'objectif est
d'éviter une guerre aux portes de
l'europe un projet redouté par les
occidentaux a toujours niée par les
russes alors avant de rencontrer
vladimir poutine emmanuel macron a
consulté un large panel de dirigeants
notamment joe biden le président
américain ou encore le porte le premier
ministre britannique boris johnson merci
nadège ad razak alors comment
interpréter les échanges et cette
conférence de presse commune à venir on
va aller plus loin avec nos invités
c'est l'heure du décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler le général
dominique trinquant expert en
géostratégie un conseiller défense
emmanuel macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 bonsoir général
merci d'être avec nous à nos côtés
également emmanuel leroy président de
l'institut 17 17 pour une nouvelle
alliance tran chorus bonsoir emmanuel
leroy merci nous accompagner en skype
également claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales et nous
rejoindra un petit peu plus tard dans ce
débat olivier bur lot qui lui nous donne
un petit peu le sentiment des français à
moscou et puisque olivier belote vous
êtes président du conseil consulaires
russie biélorussie à tout à l'heure donc
ça fait quoi maintenant quatre heures à
peu près que ça dure
général le train quand quatre heures de
discussions on s'attendait à des
discussions longues et le kremlin
l'avait dit l'elysée aussi ça prendra le
temps qu'il faudra oui ça prendra le
temps de sous la forme d'un face à face
que le président de macron affectionne
de se retrouver face à on l'a vu dans la
petite séance qui était filmé au départ
où les deux hommes se connaissent bien
je pense qu'ils s'apprécient et le
président poutine l'a dit d'ailleurs
actualité plutôt chaleur car plutôt
chaleureuse et en plus dans le contexte
dans lequel on et souvenons nous qu'il y
a quinze jours à peu près
le président poutine se retrouver face
au président bailon on se retrouvait
dans la situation près années 90 russie
etats-unis on parlait pas des européens
au même moment le président macron
intervenez au parlement français pardon
au parlement européen en parlant de du
format normandie et du fait que l'europe
devait y être relié en tant que
président français par an en tant que
président européen mais ceci étant il
joue un peu les précurseurs il a appelé
tous les européens tous les européens
qui un à un à mon avis doivent lui dire
qu'il faut négocier alors qu'autour de
la table c'est plus compliqué donc je
crois qu'il est dans une position
intéressante j'ai entendu parler de
persévérance donc je n'échappe pas au
plaisir de vous citer le le prince
d'orange qui disait qu'il n'était pas
nécessaire
d'espérer pour entreprendre ni de
réussir pour persévérer et bien le
président macron persévère et je pense
qu'il a raison je pense pas qu'il ya un
résultat une fumée blanche qui va sortir
à la fin mais au moins la voie de la
diplomatie et racé club blanche maison
quand vous avez vu ces deux hommes
s'installer le long de cet immense table
c'est vrai que l'image était assez
cocasse
il ya une forme de chaleur peut-être qui
se dégage est en tout cas de respect ça
augure peut-être de de bonnes
discussions franches et viriles mais
dans le respect ce sont d'ailleurs deux
hommes qui se respecte on peut dire ça
sans se tromper
ou jeu que la distance physique eux
n'avaient pas d'autre signification que
le sanitaire est en réalité les deux
hommes se connaissent bien et je crois
s'apprécient je crois d'ailleurs que
le président pauthe il a été assez
fasciné par l' aventure électorale du
président macron il est à 5 ans caracole
cas personnage aussi jeunes sans aucun
parti politique puisse gagner les
élections présidentielles françaises et
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter à
beaucoup de reprises alors monsieur
mâcon vient avec plusieurs casquettes
comme ça a déjà été dit hiver en effet
le prétendent la république française
bien sûr la république française qui est
membre du conseil de sécurité mais il
est aussi un des protagonistes d'une
forme à normandie et ceci il le partage
avec le président poutine et le
chancelier allemand et puis il est aussi
pendant quelques mois le président du
conseil de l'union européenne et à ce
titre et il a des choses à dire alors
bien entendu il n'a pas de mandat précis
des européens mais après tout il peut
faire une mission exploratoire et voir
quelles seraient les thermes au chi qui
permettrait de progresser dans la ds
canal avec le président macron y compris
sur des sujets qui sont les sujets de
sécurité et même si l'union européenne
n'a pas de véritables compétences en
matière de sécurité puisqu'elle n'a pas
d'armé elle a un poids considérable en
matière économique et là aussi les
propositions peuvent peut-être être
évoquée emmanuel leroy vous l'ami de la
russie 1 vous vous prenez en tout cas ce
rapprochement vous avez de grands
espoirs ce soir entouré c'est une bonne
chose que ces deux hommes se rencontrent
toutes façons les contacts sont toujours
préférables à l'affrontement bien
évidemment donc mais pour ma part et au
risque de jouer les rabat joie je vous
avouerai que je n'attends pas grand
chose de cette rencontre que j'assimile
beaucoup plus apte delà des postures de
type diplomatique ou politique mais je
ne crois pas qu'ils n'en sortira grand
chose d'abord pour la première raison
c'est que les russes se sont adressés
non pas à la france et nier non plus à
l'union européenne mais aux états unis
et à l'otan ce sont eux les
interlocuteurs se sont eux qui ont reçu
les lettres leur demandant de clarifier
la position de l'otan à l'égard de la
russie la france et l'a hélas la france
et das et l'union européenne non plus
n'ont pas été conviés à ce discours
comme si elles n'étaient pas considérés
comme des interlocuteurs valables
toutefois le kremlin a jugé
l'interlocuteur intéressant c'est que le
kremlin et
il ne pourrait pas jouer un rôle de
médiateur finalement emmanuel macron
dans cette affaire c'est exactement le
jaune rôle qui veut jouer dans le rôle
de puissance d' équilibre
d'essayer de jouer un rôle
après et je suis d'accord au départ le
président poutine a voulu discuter avec
le président biden et il ya eu le tort à
mon avis de présenter une position
écrite dont il savait que la réponse
serait négative et donc pour se sortir
de ce guêpier si j'ose dire maintenant
faut trouver d'autres moyens et c'est là
que le président en nacre on peut
essayer de son de jouer ce rôle je suis
assez d'accord je disais que la fumée
blanche ne sortira pas ce soir c'est
probable mais ceci étant
les lignes oui mais ceci étant demain il
sera à kiev parce que la partie de kiev
a son rôle à jouer aussi un rappel que
l'accord de minsk s'est pas uniquement
la partie russe qui doit faire quelque
chose la partie ukrainienne doit bouger
bien sûr beaucoup de choses sont
aujourd'hui dans les mains de ce qui est
exactement donc c'est le rôle qui va qui
va jouer devant demain je pense que au
delà de la crise ukrainienne bien au
delà il ya le problème de la sécurité en
europe qui que le président poutine a
mis sur la table et là il ya des choses
qui ont été oubliés depuis des années
parce qu'on pensait que c'était évident
mais les mesures de confiance qu'on
appelait les mesures de confiance ont
été totalement abandonnée et il faut les
remettre sur la table et là je pense que
il faut élever le débat et profiter de
cette situation pour essayer de pacifier
les rapports j'ose dire encore entre
l'est et l'ouest mais qui devrait plus
être des rapports de ce type tout ceci
ce sont des pays européens et qui est je
suis heureux que ce soit un président
d'un pays européen qui traite de
problèmes européens et non pas
uniquement les états unis avec la russie
sur cette confiance justement je
voudrais vous faire écouter ce passage
important hier dans le journal du
dimanche à emmanuel macron qui parle
justement du point de vue russe
nous devons donc protéger nos frères
européens en proposant un nouvel
équilibre capable de leur préserver la
souveraineté et la paix il faut le faire
en même temps dans le respect de la
russie et en comprenant les propres
traumatismes contemporain de ce grand
peuple et de cette grande nation j'ai
toujours été dans un dialogue profond
avec le président poutine est notre
responsabilité de bâtir des solutions
historiques il y a je crois une
disponibilité du président poutine pour
cela emmanuel leroy c'est un passage
certainement important emmanuel macron
qui parle aussi du besoin légitime de la
sécurité de la russie on n'a peut-être
pas toujours assez parlé dans ce dossier
ce que c'est pas ce qu'attend
aujourd'hui la russie entrent en compte
c'est la question clé et je voudrais
dire on en préalable que la raison de
cette crise ce n'est pas l'armée russe
aux frontières de l'ukraine c'est
l'armée ukrainienne dont la moitié des
effectifs sont basés sur les frontières
du donbass depuis maintenant près d'un
an et qui menace d'attaquer à tout
moment donc le véritable danger il est
là et ce que je voudrais dire sur cette
cave chose à faire ce que la france
effectivement un rôle clé à jouer dans
la résolution de cette crise avec la
l'application des accords de minsk je
rappelle effectivement que la france
comme l'allemagne et la russie sont les
garants d application de ces accords qui
n'ont jamais étaient ce qu'on dirait se
satisfait par par kiev j'avais encore ce
matin des contacts avec des amis
présents dans le donne pas ce qu'ils
font et encore ce matin de bombardements
de l'armée ukrainienne sur des
populations civiles et ça ce n'est
jamais ti dans la presse occidentale
que ce soit donc aux états unis ou en
europe c'est un point important ces
accords de minsk doivent être réglés et
le président macron demain à kiev je
l'espère
abordera cette question de manière
précise avec le président vienne ce qui
de manière à ce que ces accords soient
enfin respectés avant de retrouver au
lit et burnotte pas avoir un petit peu
le sentiment des français sur place au
club blanchemaison sur ces accords de
mines ce que c'est l'une des pistes
évidemment et c'est l'une des clés de ce
qui est en train de se tramer entre
venir poutine et emmanuel macron
je crois qu'on a perdu claude gans
maison vous nous entendez ah oui pardon
oui je vous en prie je vais je pense que
c'est l'une des pistes en effet et pour
emmanuel macron puisqu'il a toujours
marqué la plus grande importance au rôle
de la france et l'allemagne et la russie
devaient jouer dans les accords de minsk
est en effet il faut appliquer les
accords de me disent que je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut
inciter le président ukrainien à
appliquer les accords de minsk
évidemment le président ukrainien ça
n'est pas très simple parce qu'il a
aussi un parlement et que dans son
parlement il ya des forces qui sont
hostiles à l'application de certaines
dispositions
donc comme dans tout pays il faut tenir
compte des différentes forces en
présence alors je crois que en effet le
président de la république aussi
aujourd'hui a sans doute plus rassuré
son interlocuteur en rappelant que la
france comme d'ailleurs l'allemagne
avait indiqué en 2008 qu'elle était tout
à fait hostile à l'entrée de l'ukraine
et de la géorgie dans l'otan et qui a
pas de raison que cette position est
changée d'autant plus que ces pays / dpi
divisée et que l'otan n'acceptera pas
qu'ils importent à l'intérieur de
l'organisation le conflit le conflit
interne donc je pense que ceci fait
beaucoup avancer les choses et que on a
un système de négociation est enfin de
se diversifier
via une négociation avec les américains
qui la négociation sur les questions
stratégiques
mais il ya une négociation dans le car
normandie qui a été
revigoré par la réunion il ya une
dizaine de jours qui va continuer à
berlin le 10 février et puis il y a les
autres questions sur lesquelles le
président de macs ont certainement va
revenir avec une une idée très précise
de ce que veut le président poutine en
matière d'assurance de sécurité pour la
sécurité de la russie et là c'est
probablement l'objet de toutes ces
heures de discussions l'une des lignes
rouges on le sait ont évidemment l'a
répété à 1 c c'est l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan est ce que la
finlandisation comme on dit 'de de
l'ukraine est ce que ça va être là aussi
l'une des clés est peut-être l'une des
solutions qui peut être abordée
j'entendis là il ya deux façons de
sortir de cette crise pour l'ukraine en
tout cas la première serait non pas la
finlandisation mais
l'adoption d'une neutralité réel comme
celles comme celle de l'autriche ou la
suisse c'est la première façon que
l'ukraine aurait donc de sortir de sa
crise insoluble et la seconde se serait
donc de laisser des populations
russophones et russophiles de l'ukraine
rejoindre librement la russie ce serait
à mon avis des deux façons de calmer la
situation
cela étant ce n'est pas le fond du
problème le fond du problème ce que
véritablement la demande de la russie
pour sortir de cette situation de crise
qui ne concerne pas que l'ukraine et de
dunbar mais qui concerne l'ensemble du
dispositif de sécurité européen ce
serait que l'otan c'est que l'otan
revienne à ses frontières de 1997 c'est
à dire qu'on revienne à une situation de
calme diplomatique de sécurité pour le
pour tout le monde pour tout le monde et
que la russie s'engage bien évidemment
assurer la sécurité de ses voisins
immédiats notamment les pays baltes la
pologne s'était abaissée la solution
c'est la seule solution de paix qui peut
se dessiner dans les mois qui viennent
et je pense que nous allons y revenir
d'une manière ou d'une autre car la
russie aujourd'hui a prouvé qu'elle
avait les moyens de sa politique vous
êtes d'accord c'est parce que
une solution n'est pas une solution pour
une raison simple c'est que ce n'est pas
l'otan qui décide mais ce sont les pays
qui décident librement de rejoindre
l'otan ou l'union européenne et les pays
faut le rappeler quand même qu'ils ont
été occupées par l'union soviétique
depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale ont un très mauvais souvenir de
la présence des forces russes ou
soviétiques de l'époque pardon et que ce
souvenir est toujours persistant dans
ces pays et qu'aujourd'hui ces pays ont
pris librement le choix de rejoindre
l'otan on va pas les faire revenir en
arrière là dessus en revanche il ya des
dispositifs physiques militaires qui
peuvent ne pas être présent aux
frontières qui peuvent ne pas allumer
des flammèches de conflits ça c'est un
autre sujet mais aujourd'hui demander
aux pays qui ont librement choisi de
rejoindre le temps de quitter le temps à
mon avis c'est un homme starter comme on
dit c'était pas sortir de l'otan c'était
au moins de démilitariser ces zones et
notamment en supprimant les systèmes de
missiles qui sont aujourd'hui donc des
systèmes qui permettent d'atteindre
moscou saint pétersbourg sans aucune
restriction c'est la lada la grande
crainte des bus et on peut la comprendre
ça a été la proposition qui a fuité dans
dans le journal espagnol d'il ya
quelques jours dans laquelle les
américains ont dit écoutez pas de
problème vous allez venir vérifier qu'il
n'ya pas de site domicile et nous nous
allons vérifier de votre côté qui a pas
de cible de missiles c'est ce que
j'appelle les mesures de confiance qui
existait il ya encore vingt ans et qui
ont été balayés par l'oubli par la
mauvaise volonté
considération si parfois de de la russie
il ya eu
dans la bouche de certains dirigeants
occidentaux d'ailleurs mais c'est ce
qu'a dit le président macron ce que vous
avez fait passer tout à l'heure qui est
très très juste il faut prendre en
compte l'histoire ancienne bien sûr avec
en particulier l'ukraine mais aussi
l'histoire depuis les années 2000
globalement et que dont poutine à la
mémoire puisque ça fait 21 ans qu'il est
au pouvoir donc il a bien cette mémoire
la toul et les dirigeants européens ne
l'ont pas forcément ils ont une durée un
peu plus courte
et donc il faut que tout ceci plus soit
pris en compte bien sûr on va aller voir
du côté de moscou un ce qu'on pense
justement les français sur place olivier
bur lot
justement quel est le sentiment des
français que vous croisez avec lesquels
vous avez pu échanger ces derniers jours
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup d'attentes pour
cette rencontre marquant poutine
aujourd'hui
oui bonsoir à tous bien sûr ici on a un
seul souci c'est de s'assurer que le
dialogue reprend même si c'est pas un
dialogue bilatéral franco-russe c'est un
dialogue européen avec peut-être plus de
moyens plus de poids mais le plus
important c'est qu'heuliez du dialogue
on parle de mesures de confiance on
vient de parler de ça mais enfin il faut
pas oublier que les états unis sont
sortis du traité openskies récemment ça
ça c'est clairement un mauvais signal
donc en fait on avait des outils
visiblement il ya eu de la tension il
est clair aussi que la débâcle
américaine en afghanistan a tout
déstabilisé maintenant on assiste à un
redéploiement des troupes en europe bien
évidemment la situation en ukraine et
très conflictuelle donc tout ce qu'il
peut aller dans le sens du dialogue est
une bonne chose et on se réjouit de
cette visite bien sûr on ne sait pas ce
qui va en sortir il faut attendre demain
également
l'agenda du président qu'il s'est lui
même fixée pour pouvoir être candidat
aux présidentielles à savoir résoudre
l'ukraine et éventuellement locaux vides
et un agenda très ambitieux mais c'est
positif et nous on laquelle comme tel
par contre ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que au niveau des russes du
quotidien on ne sent pas d'inquiétude
ils sont bien évidemment certains le
niveau militaire la force et de leur
côté évidemment ils ne veulent pas de
guerre ils le disent tous mais on
constate il faut quand même bien voir
que ils ont massé des troupes au sol il
faut pas oublier qu'en syrie ils ont
gagné ils ont sauvé le régime par des
troupes au sol et l'otan évidemment en
face ne peut pas aligner cent mille
hommes voilà donc espérons que tout ceci
va
revenir vers un dialogue constructif et
c'est notre souhait le plus cher au club
danse maison justement c'est assez
intéressant ce que nous dit olivier
d'antin parce que rien sauvage ailleurs
qu'il le prouve 53 % des russes qui
jugent improbable ont exclu l'hypothèse
d'une guerre avec leurs voisins il ya
plus d'inquiétude du côté curieusement
européen on parle parfois même des
d'hystérie du côté américain
c est ce qu il lui même qui le disaient
vous êtes justement d'accord
écoutez moi je suis professionnellement
optimiste parce que lorsque il n'y a
plus de place sur la diplomatie pardon
mon général nous laissons la place aux
militaires par conséquent je pense que
la diplomatie est en oeuvre qu'elle est
complexe elle est très diversifiée comme
je l'étais tout à l'heure par divers
canaux en fonction des compétences des
uns et les autres et je crois que tout
ça devrait converger en effet vers des
résultats mais ça prendra du temps bien
entendu ça sera pas demain matin ça va
prendre un certain temps et pendant que
ces négociations ont lieu eh bien on ne
sait pas la guerre donc je crois que
c'est ça l'objectif recherché par macron
en concertation d'ailleurs avec avec
tous ses partenaires européens et si on
pouvait dans les prochaines semaines et
dans les prochains mois progresser sur
la la sphère du dombass ce serait un
très bon si un très bon signal bien
entendu mais comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure sur votre plateau l'ukraine
n'est qu'une partie du sujet le sujet
c'est ce que demande la lumière poutine
pour ceux qu'ils estiment devoir être là
la sécurité de la russie et ça c'est une
négociation qui est largement entre lui
et les américains puisque en effet
il ne veut pas que des systèmes d'armes
soient stationnés dans des pays qui ont
rejoint l'otan ou qui n'ont pas rejoint
l'otan mais qui sont qui ont une
frontière commune avec la russie et ça
c'est une négociation qui peut
parfaitement se dérouler entre entre
entre moscou et washington
donc moi je pense qu'il est possible
d'arriver à une solution ça ne sera pas
ça ne sera pas très simple mais il faut
abandonner toutes les questions de
principe il faut
regarder chaque problème suivant ses
mérites propres et lui trouver une
solution une solution par la négociation
bien sûr et je pense que c'est
techniquement possible
donc moi ce soir je suis plutôt
optimiste sinon je ne vois pas pourquoi
monsieur poutine aurait reçu monsieur
macron pourquoi la discussion a duré
aussi longtemps ni pourquoi monsieur
poutine aurait accepté que la
négociation en format normandie
reprennent alors qu'elle était gelé
depuis maintenant deux ans donc il ya
des signes qui indiquent que de part et
d'autre la volonté de bouger et de
trouver des solutions j'ajoute que oui
dans les pardons d'origine peule aux
forces ce qui avait été évoqué tout
ajout de mettre au panier parce que on a
parlé de sommet avec baden de sommet
avec l'os ans mais il manque un sommet
c'est le fameux sommet que monsieur
macro et madame merkel vous avons
proposé à leurs partenaires sans succès
en juin dernier un sommet entre la
russie l'union européenne unie obtient
généralement donnez-moi creuse
blanchemaison gc distribuer la parole
sur ce plateau aussi c'est vrai que
c'est ça a été très commenté le fait qu
emmanuel macron viennent tout seuls n'y
aurait pas eu plus de poids de venir
avec olaf scholz qui est lui allé voir
joe biden il fallait arriver alors enfin
ce nom si sauf que le chancelier
allemand vient d'arriver qu'il est
probablement aller régler quelques
problèmes germano américain en
particulier les problèmes de gaz
directement à washington et que comme je
le disais tout à l'heure le président
macron a pris le soin d'appeler
individuellement tous les européens pour
avoir leur point de vue et autour d'une
table et 27 européens devraient
probablement pas eu la même position
comme le disait ambassadeur
blanchemaison ils ont refusé le dialogue
pour l'instant il ya dans le rapport de
force il ya un point qu'on ne souligne
pas là c'est le problème de le temps
après ça a été soulignée à moscou après
la catastrophique opérations de kaboul
les américains ont besoin de réunifier
le temps et cette espèce de montée en
gamme aujourd'hui par les américains et
les phares et balises en particulier sur
la menace qui n'est même pas reconnue
par le gouvernement ukrainien a lui-même
a pour objet de réunir tous les pays de
l'otan sous la halle des américains et
ça ça c'est un facteur qu'il faut avoir
vu et je pense que c'est un peu le piège
dans lequel est tombé monsieur poutine
paradoxalement monsieur poutine
ressuscitent le temps parce que han
nommé montant en gamme lui même il a
revivifié les réflexes des européens qui
sont pointe ce point de salut hors des
états unis et donc je pense que la
manoeuvre du président macron
aujourd'hui est de revenir à la
diplomatie par le biais du du dialogue
établi sur le format la normandie et de
pouvoir enfin discuter politique et non
pas ce rapport de force
assurément donc ce que tu général est
juste sur la première partie en revanche
je considère que la la position de
l'europe aujourd'hui n'est pas crédible
elle n'est pas crédible parce que
politiquement l'europe ne parle pas
d'une seule voix tu ne l'a vu c'est un
conte un contexte totalement hétérodoxes
qui n'est absolument pas unifié on a vu
récemment le président croate affirmé
qu'il refuserait de suivre le temps bien
qu'ils soient membres de l'otan en cas
de conflit entre la russie et l'ukraine
donc l'europe n'a pas de poids politique
et je pense que plus encore que cela le
plus important noté me semble-t-il c'est
que l'otan a perdu la suprématie
militaire ça c'est un point qui n'est
pas souligné hélas dans les médias
occidentaux
mais il y a depuis au moins 2013 au
moins depuis depuis 2013 et avec une
redondance en 2018 la preuve je dis bien
la preuve absolue que ni les états unis
ni l'otan ne maîtrisent les armes du
futur c'est à dire que la russie
aujourd'hui à apporter des preuves
qu'elle était largement en avance sur
l'occident et que désormais l'otan
n'étaient plus en mesure d'imposer sa
force et sa domination et je pense c'est
une chance historique pour l'europe de
sortir enfin de sortir enfin de la
domination des états unis est d'essayer
de retrouver en tout cas pour la france
de retrouver cette position d' équilibre
qui a toujours été la sienne
lorsqu'elle avait une certaine
souveraineté et qu'elle a hélas perdu
depuis qu'elle s'est mise à la remorque
de l'union européenne et de l'otan en
particulier me rater français à moscou
ils pensent la même chose qu emmanuel
leroy en substance en gros c'est une
occasion pour pour l'europe de
s'émanciper des états unis
oui tout à fait simplement c'est vrai
que peut constater que malheureusement
pour le côté français on arrive en toute
fin de mandat du président macron en
plus dans une campagne et prédit un site
qui commence où il ne se déclare pas
candidat donc tout ça ce sont des
mauvais points je dirais mais bien sûr
on continuait à penser qu' il faut que
la france retrouve de la souveraineté je
veux dire c'était évident on ne peut pas
être respectée si on ne se respecte pas
soi même voilà donc ça c'est très clair
at rappelant que la france soit un
moteur de l'europe ça n'est pas une
surprise et je pense que la crise
actuelle est l'illustration grâce à la
volonté du président macron d'être un
moteur il vient en tant que président
français mais en essayant de changer la
position européenne rome ne s'est pas
fait en un jour et réunir 27 pays ça
n'est pas spécialement surtout avec des
histoires différentes du rappel je
rappelle le traumatisme de l'occupation
soviétique faut pas l'oublier quand vous
allez dans les pays baltes comme vous
allez en pologne je vais vous dire je
vous dit vous êtes bien gentil les
français mais vous vous n'avez pas connu
ça non là connu et donc voilà il ya un
moment où si la russie ne doit pas jouer
le rôle qu'a joué l'union soviétique et
faut faire oublier un peu cette partie
de l'histoire aussi merci à tous les
trois en tout cas nous avons apporté
votre point de vue votre décryptage
olivier berlie que je pense maison
général traquant et emmanuel leroy sur
ce plateau merci à l'e3 version emmanuel
macron en tête à tête donc avec vladimir
poutine on nous dit que les deux hommes
sont en train de dîner un la france donc
partie prenante des discussions dit au
format normandie dans le dossier
ukrainien qui regroupe paris et moscou
mais donc également kiev et berlin
cyrielle médaille deiss bulbul en
modèle normandie ou format normandie est
utilisé pour la première fois le 6 juin
2014 lors des commémorations du 70e
anniversaire du débarquement
une journaliste de yusei press agency
emploie l'expression pour désigner la
réunion qui vient d'avoir lieu entre les
quatre chefs d'état bladimir poutine
président russe
petro porochenko président ukrainien en
gala merkel chancelière allemande et
françois hollande président français au
centre des discussions le règlement du
conflit craignant et notamment de la
guerre civile du dombass qui a éclaté en
avril 2014
c'est la première fois depuis le début
de la crise que les deux voisins
dialogue le duo franco-allemand qui
tente de jouer les médiateurs imagine
alors la mort ce d'une désescalade
dès lors les réunions s'enchaînent en
présentiel ou en virtuel entre chefs
d'état entre ministres des affaires
étrangères ou encore entre représentants
politiques
etc
[Musique]
m
on
tous
[Musique]
où
donc
m
si ces multiples formats normandie n'ont
jamais abouti à un consensus ou une
désescalade effective des tensions dans
l'est de l'ukraine cette dernière
réunion fin janvier a selon l'élysée
envoyer un signal positif
la prochaine rencontre de ce type est
prévue à berlin le 10 février
alors au delà des discours politiques
qu'en est il des populations sur place
comment vivent tels cette crise
ukrainienne on en parle tout de suite
avec nos invités sur ce plateau donc
régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france bons soient régis merci d'être
avec nous et avec nous également jérôme
sessini reporter photographe membre de
magnum photos bonsoir jérôme sessini on
est particulièrement ravis de vous
accueillir vous êtes membre donc je le
disais de même photo prix pierre et
alexandra boulât plusieurs fois lauréat
du world press photo et surtout vous
avez couvert de nombreux conflits et des
zones de guerre dont évidemment
l'ukraine vous avez publié ce livre
alors je ne sais pas si on le voit à la
caméra c'est pas évident inner 10 heures
l'ukraine 2014 2017 1 vous documenter
ainsi six années guerre aux portes de
l'europe et on découvre clairement ces
instants de vie où l'humain est le coeur
de votre travail justement l'humain ça
nous intéressait parce que on voit
toujours les discours des dirigeants
prendre voilà
parler du sort d'un pays on parle un
petit peu moins des populations ce sont
des grands oubliés finalement de ce qui
se joue en ce moment les populations
absolument - c'est d'ailleurs toute la
mon approche photographique dans ce
travail était justement de me mettre à
hauteur du main et
dense et difficile surtout avec la
question ukrainienne est là aussi deux
pas
il ya beaucoup propagande de part et
d'autre donc moi je voulais évacuer ce
problème et raconter vraiment la vie le
quotidien des humains d'abord un maidan
c'est commencer et ensuite j'ai suivi le
mouvement ce qui est devenu une vraie
guerre ensuite dans l'est vous avez
passé des mois par des années en ukraine
vous avez vécu justement cette crise
maiden le soulèvement l'une se voir
d'ailleurs source sur les photos quand
vous nous parlez on découvre vos photos
également vous n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs
à les commenter alors là il s'agit c'est
une photo que j'ai prise à mario paul
avant ces deux membres d'un bataillon
deux miliciens ukrainien bataillon azoff
qui était dans un moment de détente sur
la plage alors voilà revoir si la régie
veut bien nous remettre cette photo /
sur la page de ces deux hommes
voilà la régie on
voit là pour ça ça va revenir ça va
revenir on va oui et donc un moment
détente de ces deux hommes oui ces deux
hommes d'un bataillon de volontaires qui
se battent pour kiev pour le
gouvernement ukrainien et qu'ils étaient
dans leurs casernes et qui à un moment
donné sont sortis pour se détendre et
l'ong seul moyen de s'amuser ce avec une
arme voilà
régis c'est vrai que cette expérience
est importante parce que on a du mal
souvent quand on parle là de ce qu'on
fit s'imaginer ce que vivre ces gens en
ukraine qu ils sont d'ailleurs souvent
extrêmement divisés c'est un pays
extrêmement fracturée l'ours est un pays
extrêmement fracture mais en même temps
qui a une destinée commune aussi on peut
pas croire que l'est et l'ouest si on
peut les diviser comme ça en ukraine est
vécue complètement séparément dans moi
ce que j'aurais pu poser comme questions
à jérôme c'est tout lui qui a couvert
les deux camps est ce qu'il ya un gros
sentiment tenace de part et d'autre ou
est ce qu'il existe encore aujourd'hui
au stade au moment où on en parle parce
que ces deux républiques existe à l'est
et puis il ya l'ouest est ce que ces
deux camps sont irréconciliables au
niveau des populations ou non non moi
c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup choqué moi ce
que je ne connaissais pas du tout
d'ukraine première fois c'était en
février 2014 quand j'ai découvert maidan
et très vite je me suis aperçu qu'il y
avait une une fracture mais vraiment
très profonde
a l'impression de franchir à chaque fois
que je partais j'arrivais à kiev j'ai
des amis à kiev et que je disais je vais
dans le donbass il me disait mais tu es
fou
tu vas chez les sauvages tu vas chez les
tu vas te faire tuer il faut pas aller
là-bas
l'impression qu'il ya deux réalités de
pays de réalité qui ne se connaissent
pas qui ne se parlent pas quand vous
parliez de ça il n'y avait pas encore
cette division c'était à maidan et vous
alliez dans le combat s'il n'est pas
encore de séparation samaille amaidan
n'était pas aussi
évident mais on sentait qu'il y avait
déjà des câbles et les premières
manifestations maidan il faut savoir
aussi que la vie bon nous on a vu les
manifestations depuis l'occident d'une
certaine façon qu un côté un peu
romantique mais pour les gens du donbass
il avait une tout autre lecture des
événements pour eux
le maïdan c'était quelque chose qui leur
a fait peur en fait puisque ça rappelait
bon les mouvements anti soviétique de la
seconde guerre mondiale qui
réapparaissait enfin le nanisme créé
nationalisé par fournira et tout a
commencé par des rats et pour eux ils
ont vraiment pris peur alors après ils
ont été peut-être
conditionné aussi par la certaine
propagande mais il y avait déjà au
départ de toute façon une certaine
méfiance de part et d'autre aujourd'hui
ce que vous estimez que ici en occident
on a une forme de vision extrêmement
manichéenne de de ce dossier ukrainien
oui je trouve un peu mois maintenant
mais je me souviens en 2014 c'était
c'était très huit mannequins il y avait
d'un côté les
les gentils donc qui était pro européen
et de l'autre côté les méchants
qui était vendu enfin totalement soumis
à la russie ce qui est totalement enfin
moi j'ai pas vu ça
moi j'ai vu simplement dans le donbass
des personnes d'aidé beaucoup de civils
ont été victimes de d'attac de
bombardements et souvent justement les
gens me disais mais pourquoi vous les
journalistes vous parlais mal de nous
pourquoi vous dites qu on est d
aider des [ __ ] des mains
mais
alors tout ce qu'on demande c'est de
vivre en paix on est des travailleurs
des gens modestes des mines beaucoup de
mineurs et voilà on ne manque de rien
j'ai jamais entendu de gens qui criaient
leur amour pour la russie pour la
lumière poutine s'est pas du tout
n'était pas du tout le cas on va peut
être s'arrêter sur quelques photos
n'hésitez pas à re était bien vous allez
photo régis s'il vous plaît parce que ça
va avoir du mal évidemment les commenter
cet homme par exemple vous souvenez dans
quelles circonstances vous avez pris
cette photo donc c'était décembre 2014
dans la banlieue de donetsk et sur la
toute proche de l'aéroport où avaient
lieu des combats à l'aéroport et tout
autour il y avait des
pilonnages de l'artillerie de l'armée
ukrainienne et donc les habitants du
quartier vivaient dans les abris
souterrains soit des caves soit parfois
même des anciens abri de la seconde
guerre mondiale qui avait été réouvert
pour
pour ce conflit
aujourd'hui régis quand on voit des
photos de jérôme sessini son travail
qu'on entend ces témoignages
on imagine que l'attention doit être à
son comble en ukraine et que les gens ne
veulent surtout pas revivre
ça je crois que c'est ce qui est
intéressant en ce moment il y en a pas
mal de confrère jérôme et moi qui sont
là bas plutôt côté ukrainien est bon il
y à il ya une sorte d'attentes de de
commandes de paix armée qui se met en
place avec des entraînements de civils
avec des kalachnikov en bois avant elles
font fait il ya tout un tas de remise de
conditionnement de la défense civile qui
se met en place mais on sent bien dans
les témoignages qui sont recueillis il y
en a eu quelques-uns aussi du côté du
côté des deux républiques
doullens et de deux nièces qu de l'autre
côté
que personne n'a envie
qu'il y ait la guerre c'est assez
sensible les témoignages des gens qui
ont vécu 2014 je pense que jérôme
pourrait nous peut-être nous éclairer
sur ce point mais mais le ces gens là
n'ont pas envie de revivre la même
expérience et on voit même que jusqu'au
président ukrainien qui dit aujourd'hui
d'arrêter des discours apocalyptiques et
qui s'est même engueulé avec joe biden
au téléphone en 10 ans américain arrêté
de parler d'imminence d'invasion parce
que nous c'est pas là on n'a pas la même
lecture ils ont conscience que leur pays
peut devenir un véritable champ de
bataille et ça ça peut durer pendant des
décennies que toute cette zone là
peut-être mise à genoux et je pense que
c'est
de ce qu'on entend de la part des
ukrainiens de part et d'autre c'est un
peu ce message là vous leur part et
jérôme sessini j'imagine vous avez gardé
des contacts en ukraine qu'est-ce qui
vous disent effectivement aujourd'hui je
garde surtout des contacts avec des amis
à kiev avec le donbass je sais pas
pourquoi ces puces plus compliqué
mais
il y à une certain il ya une espèce de
désillusion aussi le sens de fatigue est
vraiment faim personne n'a envie de
revivre la guerre comme c'était le cas
aujourd'hui ils attendent beaucoup de
ces négociations une rencontre comme ça
il la suit avec attention et avec
beaucoup d'espoir ils attendent beaucoup
des dirigeants européens américains et
russes aujourd'hui oui évidemment c'est
ils attendent beaucoup ils attendent
surtout que
qu'il n'y ait pas d'escaladé que la
guerre ne reviennent pas fin de la
guerre est toujours là
on va dire c'est un conflit gelé pour
l'instant plus ou moins mais ils ne
veulent surtout pas de guerre
moi je voulais je vais vous demander
vous avez vous avez couvert la syrie
aussi il y avait les russes étaient
partie prenante
l'irak
comment l'ukraine est ce que c'est
c'est un conflit à part dans votre
carrière qui commet voulu juger par
rapport aux autres guerres oui vous avez
couvertes alors d'abord c'était la
proximité
avec la france qui est qui est assez
important puisque ces quelques heures
d'avion de paris de craine mais c'est
aussi une guerre où j'ai pas vraiment
enfin tous ceux qui l'ont couvert comme
moi on a été témoin de la
de la construction un peu d'une guerre
c'est à dire ces parties de
manifestation
sur la place de maidan et petit à petit
on a vu comment le conflit est
rançonnement confirmait donc ça on a pu
vivre
pratiquement au jour le jour et surtout
ce qui était très très prégnant pour moi
c'était là cette division
cette
façon fin de plus parler cette structure
qui a entre les deux les deux ukraine
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez le
traitement des médias occidentaux même
le nôtre enfin voilà des médias en
général
qu'est ce que vous vous dites que
parfois on est peut-être hors sol par
rapport à ce qui se passe là bas sur le
terrain il ya un décalage ont finalement
pas tant que ça non ça dépend bon
ben moi j'ai toujours
enfin j'ai toujours fait toujours un peu
peur quand j'entends les médias qui
parlent de façon un peu trop véhémente
et qui va comme ça a été le cas c'est le
cas actuellement qui parle d' escalade
de guerre
on a l'impression parfois qu'il qu'ils
attendent en fait un qui l'a enfin
qu'ils la veulent jeunes n'ont peut-être
pas qu'ils la veulent mais
moi je feins
une dramatisation dramatisation voit la
dramatisation pas d'être
rajoutés moi j'ai couvert quelques
conflits et je me dis toujours à chaque
fois c'est vrai qu'il ya sept cette
rhétorique qu'on entend qui a tendance à
se répéter ce espèce d'exaltation de
certains et jeudi les journalistes sont
pas indemme parce qu'il y en a qui
écrivent avec des accents pas qu'ils
souhaitent la guerre mais en tout cas
qui qui ont l'impression qu'elle va est
inéluctable et quand on va sur le
terrain et au fil des années on a
toujours ce recul et on se dit
finalement bas c'est toujours les mêmes
qui qui déclenche les guerres et c'est
toujours j'ai jamais ce qui est
déclenché qui les terminent et et de
voir ces photos là aujourd'hui et les
conséquences ou encore de ce conflit
s'était 2014 on est en 2022 c'était donc
il ya huit ans et pendant huit ans
depuis huit ans l'ukraine est un pays
qui a du mal à se relever parce que il
ya eu ce conflit et on voudrait qu'il y
en ait encore un autre enfin je dis pas
qu'on voudrait qu'il y en ait encore
d'autres mais c'est toujours moi j'ai
toujours un sérieux doute sur
ces guerres qu'on a déclenché un depuis
l'afghanistan jusqu'à la libye quand on
voit les conséquences aujourd'hui de ces
guerres quand on retourne dans ces pays
là on voit des pays anéantis et bien on
n'a surtout pas envie vraiment pas ce
qu'on a vu sa
de revoir la même chose et en
particulier dans une zone comme
l'ukraine qui est comme le disait jérôme
très proche de nous très proche de
l'europe ça serait dommageable pour tout
le monde merci beaucoup régie se soigne
et jérôme sessini d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france et on le disait
donc emmanuel macron qui est toujours en
ce moment à moscou en train en tête à
tête avec des maires poutine quatrième
président en france et qui à faire au
président russe quelle relation n ya pas
une entretient-il avec paris éléments de
réponse avec quentin moncler et maxime
grossière non pas un ni deux mais c'est
bien trois présidents français que
vladimir poutine a pu côtoyer avant
l'arrivée d'emmanuel macron à l'elysée
sept ans pour jacques chirac 5 pour
nicolas sarkozy et françois hollande est
avec chacun les relations sont loin
d'avoir été un long fleuve tranquille à
son arrivée à la tête du kremlin en 1999
vladimir poutine voit ses rapports avec
jacques chirac se tendre presque
immédiatement pour autant les deux
hommes vont peu à peu se découvrir des
convergences de vues et chirac qui
s'inscrit dans la tradition gaulliste le
vrai pour l'intégration de la russie au
g7 et à l'om c'est point d'orgue de ce
rapprochement en 2003 l'opposition
communale intervention militaire en irak
souhaitée par les états unis en 2006
jacques chirac le fait grand croix de la
légion d'honneur la russie lui rendra la
pareille deux ans plus tard en le
décorant du prix d'état sa plus haute
distinction pour sa contribution au
renforcement de l'amitié russo française
le leader qui m'a le plus impressionné
c'était l'ancien président français
jacques chirac c'est un vrai
intellectuel un vrai professeur un homme
riche en savoir tout en étant très
intéressant quand il était président il
avait son propre avis sur chaque
question et il savait comment le
défendre en respectant toujours les
opinions de ses partenaires 2007 nicolas
sarkozy accède à l'elysée leur première
rencontre en juillet 2007 au sommet du
g8 bruisse de rumeurs selon lesquelles
le nouveau chef d'état français aurait
souhaité affirmer son autorité sur
vladimir poutine notamment sur le
respect des droits de l'homme et la
situation en tchétchénie selon un
journaliste français le président russe
aurait répondu ton pays il est comme ça
et mon pays il est comme ça maintenant
tu as deux solutions ou bien tu
continues à parler sur ce ton et je
t'écrase ou alors tu change de registre
et je peux te faire roi d'europe en août
2008 le conflit en ossétie du sud ravive
des tensions entre l'europe et la russie
nicolas sarkozy est alors à la
présidence de l'union européenne pendant
six mois le fameux contrat des porte
hélicoptères mistral signe en 2011 abbès
20 ans les relations entre les deux pays
et c'est finalement sous françois
hollande que les relations franco russes
se dégrade le plus la france qui s'était
engagé à fournir deux navires mistral
pour un milliard deux cent mille euros à
moscou rompt le contrat en 2015 paris
cède sous la pression de ses alliés qui
pointe du doigt le rattachement russe de
la crimée en 2014 et la crise dans le
donbass en 2013 à moscou le président
français surnommé monsieur petites
blagues par la presse hexagonale
s'amusait déjà de la froideur de leurs
rapports ce qui est simple avec le
président poutine c'est qu'il dit les
choses et que nous pouvons donc à partir
de là chercher la voie commune la
convergence quand elle est possible
ensuite pour la chaleur vous jugerez
vous même vous prendrez vous même
régulièrement la température de nos
relations le dossier syrien puis celui
de la crise ukrainienne donc même temps
un regain de défiance entre les deux
pays en résultent de fortes tensions qui
ont mené le président poutine a annulé
une visite officielle à paris alors
qu'il devait inaugurer une église
orthodoxe dans la capitale française
un projet de longue date il avait été
initiée pendant le mandat de nicolas
sarkozy comme un symbole des relations
en dents de scie qu'ont connu la russie
et la france durant presque deux
décennies restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de cette
rencontre et admire poutine emmanuel
macron qui se déroule en ce moment même
presque cinq heures que les deux hommes
sont en tête à tête et sont actuellement
en train de dîner et donneront une
conférence conférence de presse dans
quelques instants voire quelques heures
à la formation pour le moment alors
quelles répercussions politiques de ce
voyage pour le président français
emmanuel macron pas encore
officiellement candidat qui a pris un
risque diplomatique mais entend sans
doute capitaliser sur un éventuel succès
on en débattra avec nos analystes nos
invités
[Musique]
vous êtes médecin vous rentrez au raid
en 2007 c'était une évidence pour vous
c'est pas un choix facile vous fait le
lien entre la hiérarchie qui n'est pas
médical et les différents médecins c'est
une rencontre entre des intuitions et
puis tout votre bagage technique
bagages humains pour faire face à ces à
ce type de situation pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez choisi d'écrire sur cette
expérience c'est important après le 13
novembre j'ai entendu et élus un peu
tout et n'importe quoi une le médecin
son rôle c'est d'arriver à aborder des
sujets difficiles graves ou la mort mais
il sans cacher la vérité
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et vit la
population africaine c'est un milliard
d'habitants c'est ça à la valeur de nos
crypto monnaie
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement si nous
parce que l'argent liquide perd de la
valeur beaucoup de pays en afrique on
t'interdit
la crypto est ce que vous répondez à
cela une canette on ne peut pas dire on
va interdire la crypto d'autant qu'il ya
internet
[Musique]
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond je
suis rappelé nous pourquoi elle s'est
tournée vers le communisme il pensait
que la gauche s'étaient vendus il se
disait la démocratie la démocratie
sociale ne fait pas le travail et il a
vu l'avènement d'hitler en allemagne
donc il regardait l'union soviétique
comme un bastion anti fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
new york times le washington post the
guardian
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
il est 21 heures merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la rencontre
maquereau en ce moment-même déplacement
du président français moscou pour une
désescalade dans la crise ukrainienne
alors quelles répercussions politiques
de ce voyage pour le président français
emmanuel macron pas encore
officiellement candidat a pris un risque
diplomatique mais entend sans doute
capitaliser sur un éventuel succès
comment est perçu son initiative sur la
scène politique française quels en sont
les risques mais aussi les éventuels
bénéfices on en débattra avec nos
analystes et nos invités
[Musique]
nous avons analysé la stratégie du
président français à l approche de la
présidentielle compte rendu de cette
rencontre aujourd'hui entre vladimir
poutine et emmanuel macron à moscou elle
se poursuit toujours en ce moment même
notre correspondante one clairon suit
cette journée pour nous les précisions
tout de suite les journalistes se
trouvent toujours en salle de presse ils
n'ont toujours pas été convié dans la
salle où la conférence de presse va se
tenir autant dire que ce n'est pas
encore exactement pour tout de suite
alors pour information des plateaux
repas ont été apportés aux deux
présidents il continue donc leurs
négociations à l'heure actuelle et bien
à table j'aimerais maintenant revenir
sur les seules images que nous avons
eues pour le moment à savoir le
protocole d'accueil le moment où
vladimir poutine a accueilli son
homologue français le président russe a
dit se réjouir d'accueillir emmanuel
macron au kremlin l'occasion de pouvoir
discuter de toutes les problématiques du
moment particulier l'ukraine bien
entendu et ce en profondeur et dans un
format plus personnel que lors des
différentes conversations téléphoniques
qui ont eu lieu jusque maintenant le
président russe a également rappelé à
son homologue qu'il n'était pas le
premier président français à se frotter
à la question ukrainienne écoutez je
vois aussi que les autorités présentes
le président français
impliqués de gros efforts pour régler la
crise relative à la sécurité européenne
pour la perspective historique cela
concerne également les sujets relatifs
au règlement de la crise entre
ukrainienne à l'est du pays
durant nos échanges téléphoniques nous
avons abordé en détail
ses aspects je sais que toi tu as sa
vision
et je suis vraiment heureux d'avoir
l'opportunité de te voir en direct et en
présentiel soient bienvenues le
président russe a fait savoir que la
france était en effet impliqué dans la
raison lu tion de nombreuses
problématiques fondamentales liées à la
sécurité européenne en témoignent les
récentes les récentes conversations
téléphoniques qu'il a eus vis-à-vis de
son homologue français sur le dossier de
l'ukraine en phase manuelle macron avec
un visage plutôt fermée lors de ce
protocole d'accueil eh bien il a évoqué
une situation critique en europe au
niveau sécuritaire il a également ajouté
qu'il était bien décidé en compagnie de
ses alliés européens mais aussi de
l'otan à tendre vers la désescalade
écoutez ce dialogue est nécessaire car
c'est le seul qui permet à mes yeux de
bâtir une vraie sécurité stabilité pour
le continent européen c'est pourquoi le
contexte actuel nous avons eu ces
dernières semaines plusieurs échanges
téléphoniques tu veux rappeler et tous
ces derniers mois au demeurant malgré la
crise j'ai pu aussi échangé avec le
président aziz qui pour ce qui est de
l'ukraine mais mes coordonnées avec
de nombreux européens et alliés
qu'il s'agisse aussi des britanniques ou
des américains des canadiens et je pense
que la discussion d'aujourd'hui à mes
yeux
amorcé une
ce vers quoi nous devons aller qui est
une une désescalade dont nous
connaissons d'ailleurs les termes la
situation politico-militaire
la question et craignent end ont ils
rappelé l'importance et le format
normandie la situation sécuritaire en
biélorussie et dans toute la région et
les grandes questions évidemment de
sécurité collective dont nous allons
parler cela fait maintenant plus de 3h30
que les deux hommes discutent derrière
portes closes et tous attendent ici
désormais qu'on nous guide vers la salle
de conférence de presse afin que les
deux hommes nous livre le résultat de
leurs négociations avec cette visite à
moscou emmanuel macron veut montrer
qu'il met au centre de ses priorités la
politique étrangère le président
français qui endosse sa casquette de
président de l'europe on en parle tout
de suite avec nadège ad razak transport
léger mais nous le mettrons qui donc
rattrapés par l'actualité internationale
absolument cette crise en sur le dossier
ukrainien elle a bouleversé l agenda
politique d' emmanuel macron et cela à
deux mois de l'élection présidentielle
c'est lui qui rechignent encore à se
présenter candidat à sa propre
succession candidature dont personne ne
doute un a décidé de se mobiliser dans
ce dossier hautement explosif emmanuel
macron endosse le rôle de leader
européen dans cette crise ukrainienne et
il coordonne la position occidentale
alors avec à vladimir poutine à emmanuel
macron a tout essayé à brégançon
versailles un nombre incalculable
d'appels téléphoniques et il n'a pas
obtenu grand chose
mais il persévère pourquoi et bien parce
que l'objectif est d'éviter une guerre
aux portes de l'europe un projet redouté
par les occidentaux mais toujours niée
par les russes alors avant de rencontrer
delà des meilleures poutines emmanuel
macron à s'est entretenu avec un panel
de dirigeants joe biden le président
américain ou encore le premier ministre
a britannique boris johnson le président
français qui est donc chargé d'être le
porte-voix des européens et de ses
alliés américains face à vladimir
poutine et nadège emmanuel macron il
avait certainement une idée en tête
notamment un précédent avec un certain
nicolas sarkozy lors de la crise en
géorgie en 2008
absolument alors à l'époque nicolas
sarkozy avait profité de sa double
casquette à la présidence de la
république française et la présidence de
l'union européenne pour jouer les
médiateurs entre les différents acteurs
de la crise géorgienne sur le plan
régional mais également sur le plan
international et c'est tout à fait ce
que recherche emmanuel macron un succès
à l'international pourrait le servir sur
le plan national lui qui devrait
d'ailleurs tout prochainement annoncer
sa candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
bénéficie déjà de plus de 500
parrainages
merci nadège ad razak avec ce
déplacement est mêlé macron joue le
médiateur entre la russie et plusieurs
pays de l'union européenne un président
qui conditionne même l' annonce de sa
candidature à la présidentielle à une
désescalade des tensions entre kiev et
moscou ce qu'il manque pas de faire
réagir les politiques en france place à
notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir elie
crever l'éditorialiste rt france bonsoir
eric lowen merci d'être avec nous franck
louvrier sur ce plateau conseiller
politique de valérie pécresse candidate
les républicains évidemment la
présidentielle 2022 avec nous également
alexis poulin et litoria liste rt france
également ainsi que fabien lainé un
député modem des landes bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous une
réaction tout d'abord cette visite un là
ça fait quoi cinq heures quasiment que
les deux hommes mains venir potiner
emmanuel macron sont en train de
discuter c'est plutôt de bonne augure et
les crevel vous l'observateur de ces
jeunes filles quelques années oui oui
bon moi j'ai suivi quelques voyages
présidentiels militants de françois
mitterrand alors ils allaient moins en
russie mais
non mais non mais là c'est effectivement
l entretien a commencé à 16h30 donc ça
dure c'est sont plutôt de bonne augure
parce que sinon il ya peut-être un début
d'accord sur un point il faudra voir
parce que c'est vrai que l'entretien
comme extrêmement long alors je sais pas
si l'entretien est finie et s'il dit
maintenant voilà il dîne dont peut-être
que la discussion souvent entre deux
chefs d'état continuent évidemment
pendant le dîner mais peut-être que au
niveau international et au niveau
d'ailleurs
intérieure le président macro on va
pouvoir
accrocher avant d'être candidat au
revers de son veston un début de succès
alors les français votent jamais sur une
question internationale mais enfin lui
qui a parfois souffert d'un manque de
stature présidentielle peut être que là
il détient quelque chose franck louvrier
quand vous avez vu ces deux hommes
attablés se toiser avant cette grande
conversation qu'est ce que vous a dit
vous avez beaucoup d'attentes vous
d'abord c'est un rendez vous à la fois
franco français européen et
international bien évidemment l'europe
était très absente de cette situation
diplomatique malheureusement encore une
nouvelle fois la france est arrivé un
peu en retard de ces situations
le je dirais que binôme franco-allemand
a été assez boiteux dans cette histoire
chacun ayant des intérèts un peu
différent et c'est vrai que c'est aussi
un enjeu international pour la simple et
bonne raison c'est qu'on voit que dans
ceux tensions il y à la fois les états
unis qui joue un rôle un petit peu je
dirais qu'ils soufflent un peu sur les
braises peut-être aussi parce que leur
situation intérieure les à main faire là
et c'est vrai que le président français
se retrouve aussi à jouer un double jeu
à la fois le jeu international mais
aussi le jeu de politique intérieure
fabien lainé vous beaucoup d'attentes
pour penser à trencontre parce qu'on
nous avait un petit peu prévu en
d'emblée d'ailleurs le kremlin ça ne va
pas vraiment faire bouger les lignes
mais le fait qu'ils essaient ces
discussions nous avait aussi prévenu que
ça allait durer comprendrait le temps
c'est plutôt de bonne augure selon vous
oui il faut être dans un optimisme
prudent mais c'est une très bonne
nouvelle qu'une reprenions les
discussions avec avec les russes avec
nabih berry tine tout le monde à
emmanuel macron à a tenté de rétablir le
contact avec le président russe et si la
télé même de l'horreur de la sécurité du
continent européen que ces discussions
ce fonctionnaire bonne nouvelle emmanuel
macron et président l'union européenne
aujourd'hui pour six mois
ici lundi birkin qui a souhaité ses
entretiens avec le président de france
le plus ennuyant européenne en exercice
donc oui je pense qu'il m'a dit je crois
beaucoup consulté ses partenaires
européens nos partenaires américains
notamment dans le cas de l'auteur il va
pas les mains vides il est mandaté
aujourd'hui dans daté mais assez libre
pour négocier avec le président russe il
puis il ira à kiev comme vous le savez
demain il ira voir le nouveau chancelier
allemand l'ex-président polonais à
berlin dans deux jours oui que emmanuel
macron et dans un esprit de discussion
voilà technique mxp son diplomatique qui
critiquent aujourd'hui c'est d'un pays
qui menacent d'envahir un état souverain
pour regarder l'histoire on y reviendra
certainement mais aujourd'hui ce qui
nous intéresse c'est le respect du droit
international et la sécurité de l'europe
à ses frontières et en cela je me
réjouis que on puisse parler que le
prise en main qu'on puisse parler au
président comptines et puis peut-être
que ça permettra de percer certains
accès que nous avions depuis longtemps
avec lui aussi se parler franchement ça
peut être un gage de bonne relations à
venir
en tout cas c'est en tant que président
français emmanuel macron se déplace ce
soir et pas en tant que présidente de
l'union européenne officiellement
il a quand même beaucoup
c'est une rencontre
oui oui c'est une rencontre bilatérale
il n'a pas de demande a même si les
présidents du conseil européen il n'est
pas là pour représenter l'europe se dit
d'ailleurs tout le problème de la
diplomatie européenne qui a bien du mal
à exister nathalie l'oiseau parler d'une
suisse molle elle s'en est excusé par la
suite mais voilà un peu l'idée qu'ont
les européens de la stratégie
diplomatique européenne et puis il y a
dans cette volonté de l'admirent poutine
de parler à la france les deux pays qui
compte en europe c'est la france bien
sûr et l'allemagne avec l'intérêt on
n'en a pas encore parlé mais du gaz de
nord stream 2 qui est au coeur de cette
histoire ukrainienne puisque les
américains ont intérêt à pousser la
fermeture de nord stream et à imposer le
gaz liquéfié de provenance des états
unis sur le marché européen pour
l'allemagne ainsi que les intérêts
qatari du gaz donc il ya vraiment là une
négociation qui se fait à trois bandes
et l'idée je pense aussi de recevoir le
président français c'est d'appuyer là où
ça fait mal avec bien sûr la faire des
sous marins en asie avec la vente
annulée à l'australie où depuis la
france c'est très bien sur quel pied
danser face aux partenaires américains
qui s'est très bien avoir un partenariat
une amitié à géométrie variable en
fonction des intérêts des états unis
d'abord donc je pense que c'est
important de voir ça a presque emmanuel
macron a suffisamment de pouvoir pour
pouvoir imposer une vision non alignés
sur les intérêts de l'otan et les
intérêts américains c'est ce qu'on va
voir dans les jours qui viennent
aujourd'hui il se pose évidemment parce
qu'il est en campagne donc ça permet de
montrer qu'il est
président inter la stature
internationale qui peut résoudre un
conflit est ce que c'est ce qui va se
passer ça je ne sais pas tout dépend en
réalité de joe biden qui aujourd'hui
rencontrer olaf scholz à la maison
blanche pour parler de bien autre chose
eric revel toujours bien pour un
président pas encore candidat mais enfin
candidat quand même de montrer qu'on
parle aux grands de ce monde qu'on
essaye de régler des grands conflits à
63 jours du scrutin on prend de la haute
à bath est évident c'est évident alors
je ne dis pas que le président de la
république s'est déplacé juste dans la
perspective de sa future déclaration
comme candidat à l'élection
présidentielle mais c'est sûr que ça
aide en terme d'image évidemment ça ça
impose une stature que les autres
candidats par définition ne peuvent pas
à poser puisque ici
sur sur les sur les intérêts moi j'ai
toujours en tête cette phrase de charles
de gaulle qui disait
les états n'ont pas d'amis n'ont que des
intérêts ça il faut l'avoir en tête
parce que quand on a l'impression d'être
grugés sur un contrat d'avoir fait
confiance à des alliés historiques qui
finalement sont révélés c'est la petite
phrase si c'est ça mes amis je préfère
encore mes ennemis bon ben c'est de
cette phrase de charles de gaulle et
emmanuel macron me semble-t-il devrait
la mûrir parce que les états n'ont pas
d'amis ils n'ont que des intérêts et un
chef de l'état défend les intérêts de
son pays vladimir poutine il peut pas
admettre évidemment que l'ukraine
rentrer dans l'otan c'est comme si si si
la chine mettait une base militaire au
mexique j'imagine que les américains
réagiraient bizarrement souvenez-vous de
la crise des missiles à cuba où les
américains évidemment n'avait pas
tolérer d'avoir en face de la floride
des missiles qui pouvait atteindre les
états unis donc voilà je pense qu'il
faut l'avoir en tête cette phrase parce
que quelle que soit la position qu'on
adopte sur ce conflit potentiel en
ukraine les chefs d'états défendre les
intérêts de leur pays voilà ils peuvent
s'apprécier ou pas s'apprécier mais ça
c'est autre chose c'est bien autre chose
mais je crois franck louvrier que c'est
votre candidate un autre jour sur le
plateau de nos confrères de france
inquiète choisi cet exemple 1 2 c'est
comme si la chine mettait des missiles
au mexique valérie pécresse qui s'est
mis à part les russes on va on va
l'écouter
je veux dire aux fier peuple russe que
nous devons construire la paix en europe
et que commencer une guerre avec
l'ukraine serait une terrible erreur
alors ça c'était la version française
c'était bien plus savoureux en russe si
valérie pécresse était aux affaires
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'elle ferait
différemment des manuels macron
aujourd'hui là à l'instant où on parle
moi mon sentiment je pense qu'elle
serait partie plutôt dans la discussion
franche avec le président russe comme
vous rappeliez tout à l'heure j'ai vécu
moi 2008 et en 2008 il ya une vraie
différence avec aujourd'hui au delà du
fait que le président français était en
début de présidence française de l'union
européenne epa enfin présidence
française comme l'est aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron c'est qu' aucun
protagoniste aujourd'hui ne veut la
guerre alors qu'à l'époque la guerre il
était là et est vraiment le président
français de l'époque nicolas sarkozy a
arrêté la guerre je me rappelle très
bien de cette rencontre qui était sur la
même table autour de la même table mais
avec deux protagonistes au lieu d'un
père que je vous rappelle qu'à l'époque
dimitri medvedev était président de la
russie et vladimir venise était son
premier ministre il venait juste d'être
président de la russie que quelques mots
avant et donc de ce fait là est arrivé
en invités entre guillemets surprise
bien sûr vladimir poutine autour de la
table mais c'est vrai que le conflit
était là et le conflit était très fort
là nous sommes en discussion un peu
différente où j'ai le sentiment que ni
la russie ni les autres protagonistes ne
veuille la gare ne veuille le conflit
donc c'est plus une forme de
théâtralisation
de montrer en fin de compte quel est le
plus fort et quels sont ceux qui veulent
d'une façon ou d'une autre bien limiter
leur territoire on est en fin de compte
dans une répartition
et ce soir ce sera sans doute le cas
dans les changes quel entre le président
français et le président russe s'est une
répartition de territoire on le voit
bien à quel endroit on s'arrête et à
quel endroit on estime que chacun a sa
zone et ça va être sans doute que la
difficulté de la conférence de presse
qui va suivre c'est en fin de compte il
faut pas qu'ils perdent en et de
personnes perdent la face et donc de
cette là on peut arriver sur une
décision un peu molle pour reprendre
la terminologie d'une députée européenne
c'est-à-dire une définition qui sera pas
très clair parce que chacun veut sortir
gagnant de cette négociation et de cet
échange fabien lainé cette dramatisation
add on parle franck louvrier la range
aujourd'hui le président pas encore
candidat ça a bon dos effectivement
d'une certaine manière ça sert les
intérêts des manuels macro qui a évoqué
cette crise ukrainienne en disant voilà
qu'il attendait avant de se déclarer
candidat
non mais c'est une situation extrêmement
complexe à laquelle emmanuel macron dois
faire face moi je m'étonne quand même
dans le discours que j'entends qu'on
parle de ce qui est acceptable pour nos
amis russes ok on peut en discuter mais
j'entends que j'entends pas le seul
ouvrier par exemple aussi mouvoir des
missiles balistiques des russes sur le
cas de kaliningrad qui sont plantés sur
nos partenaires européens par exemple
sont quand même des beastie boys tikal
dix ogives nucléaires voilà je vous
rappelle que quand même dans l'ambassade
d'ukraine se sont dits des missiles
antichars keira russie donc pendant
qu'andy crème je pense pas que ça soit
en péril immédiate pour la russie donc
une fois de plus si on parle de pays
souverains de gira secondes de la france
est tout à fait légitime envahira la
wallonie parce que avance était chez
nous les italiens sont tout à fait que
légitimement rire les alpes-maritimes
parce qu'elle en dise et la corse ou si
c'était chez nous par une fois de plus
emmanuel macron l'hiver dans l'optique
de faire respecter aussi le droit
international
donc on peut discuter avec la russie sur
le sentiment de sécurité qu'elle a à ses
frontières et quelles sont ses zones
d'influencé mais bon tout aussi disputée
et l'intérêt m'anime à l'écran c'est
aussi de défendre les intérêts de
sécurité de l'union européenne et le
droit international
il s'était dans cette optique-là que les
médias marie gillain et certainement pas
dans une visée politicienne parce que il
n'a peut-être plus à perdre si ça a
échoué qu'à y gagner donc je pense que
c'est c'est courageux de sa part et une
zone plus c'est là dit mirko bibic india
invité parce que emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui l'homme sort de l'union
européenne il disait la presse
internationale enfin je veux dire chaque
analyste chaque éditorialistes en
soulignant en fait le poids des mots
dans dans l'union européenne par rapport
aux initiatives militaires par rapport
aux initiatives diplomatiques enfin
c'est quand même la france qui a porté
les initiatives européennes
d'intervention c'est la france
d'aujourd'hui qui avait jusqu'ici budget
militaire nous sommes tout à fait en
cohérence avec la place diplomatique que
notre pays porte à l'international et
emmanuel macron tout à fait crédible et
corps est ce qu il a à cet égard voilà
donc que j'entends le juge de valable
sur ce que viennent de nous dire fabien
lainé oui alors il ya évidemment de deux
façons de voir les choses et aussi la
façon de se dire qu'on est quand même
longtemps après la seconde guerre
mondiale et qu'il y encore quarante
mille soldats américains basés en
allemagne c'est peut-être anachronique
que le fait que les etats-unis soient
partout chez eux pour les opérations de
l'otan bien sûr les manoeuvres mais
aussi d'envoyer du matériel et des
troupes comme s'ils avaient des
aéroports et des bases partout le plus
grand hôpital militaire américain en
dehors des états unis c'est en allemagne
toutes les opérations également qui ont
lieu
au moyen orient par des dalles mates
donc il ya un vrai problème aussi de
souveraineté réelle de ce côté gendarme
du monde qui aujourd'hui avec un monde
multipolaire et rendu beaucoup plus
difficile
on a vu la débâcle en afghanistan on a
vu la débâcle en irak des pays qui sont
maintenant aux mains des taliban pour
l'afghanistan et dans un dans un chaos
dit délicat puisque l'état islamique
s'était installé là bas et il ya un vrai
problème il faut qu'il faut comprendre
aussi le côté pourquoi est-ce possible
pour un empire et pourquoi finalement
défendre sa frontière pour la russie se
serait vu comme quelque chose de tout à
fait belliqueux et dangereux ans
philippe mendes doté d'une boutique us
dans le dossier craignant un jean pas le
garant qui nous a rejoint dans ce débat
le député européen du rassemblement
national bonsoir jean piat garraud
marine le pen a souhaité faire sortir la
france de l'otan pour de plus je cite
être entraîné dans des conflits qui ne
sont pas les nôtres c'est ce qu'elle a
dit en substance samedi à reims au cours
de son meeting présidentiel c'est pour
vous l'un des enjeux de la
présidentielle de 2000 22
oui mais d'abord je voudrais dire que
emmanuel macron non pas du tout l'homme
fort de cette situation d'aucune façon
d'abord je sais pas si tout le monde je
pense hélas remarquer emmanuel macron
vous voyez la disposition des lieux
président poutine le reçoit une table 4
mètres de long à l'autre bout de la
table et 800 à la main il le fait
rentrer au kremlin par une zone très
dérobés mais qui peut imaginer un
général de gaulle
jacques chirac ou nicolas sarkozy
traitait cette façon là donc si vous
voulez ça veut dire simplement que le
président russe a très bien compris que
emmanuel macron il est d'un dans une
manoeuvre politicienne il va apparaître
comme celui qui va sauver la paix et de
ce côté là on arrive alors sur notre
sujet qui sont les risques réels les
risques réels de guerre donc par rapport
à la situation entre la russie et
l'ukraine il ya des spécialistes de la
question qui disent que effectivement je
l'attendais aussi sur votre plateau que
personne ne veut la guerre dans cette
histoire je me souviens d'ailleurs de
tréogat très peu de temps le vice amiral
et qui commande la marine allemande en
cra qui commandait le vice-amiral aux
chaumes bac il a dit c'est un
spécialiste il a dit non mais c'est une
ineptie le terme est une ineptie de
penser qu'il peut y avoir la guerre
entre l'ukraine et la russie alors il
l'a dit publiquement il a même dit
simplement que le président tout petit
je voulais être respectée pourquoi par
rapport évidemment à ces zones d
influence par rapport évidemment au fait
que l'otan est de plus en plus présente
à ses frontières voilà c'est ça son
problème au président russe et le vice
amiral jean de bach a été limogé parce
qu'il avait osé dire en réalité la
vérité non emmanuel macron ne pèsent pas
grand-chose à cette affaire poutine
viennent de nous le montrer et c'est
triste et ça fait mal parce qu'à travers
le président français c'est bien sûr de
la france dont il s'agit mais la voix de
la france elle ne porte plus du tout
dans le concert des nations aux mobiles
dont on parle pas du tout depuis depuis
une dizaine de minutes c'est c'est
notamment l'enjeu énergétique c'est que
derrière tout ça au chili à une forme de
rapport de force qui fait que nous
sommes dépendants nous sommes fortement
dépendants
bien sûr de la production gaz et
d'autres les allemands et les allemands
encore beaucoup plus et c'est vrai que
dans la dans la situation diplomatique
dans lequel on est on oublie parfois ce
volet qui est un volet essentiel de la
négociation et je dirais du rapport de
force ne fait qu' il est vrai le
président russe en la matière est plus
puissant que l'europe entière qui il est
vrai est elle aussi considéré comme pour
les russes comme une forme de
protectorat américain et donc de cette
la négociation n'est pas à l'heure de
deux du moment en tout cas et donc qui
il c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense que le président russe préfère
parler directement avec le président
macron plutôt qu'avec des représentants
européens qui viendraient comme le
représentant italien pour représentant
de l'europe etc donc il ya ya là aussi
je pense à prendre en compte tout
l'environnement qui n'est pas uniquement
politique mais qui est aussi bien sûr
énergétique et qui fait que la tension
était forte parce que des deux côtés ça
met en cause aussi notre indépendance
énergétique oui alors moi je dirais bien
sûr la question énergétique est très
importante mais il ya une vieille
tradition comme diplomate igolo
mitterrandienne surmonte un peu dans le
passé parce qu'il ya des liens
historiques entre la russie et la france
faut jamais l'oublier il ya des liens
amicaux il ya des liens d'histoire moi
je me souviens avoir été à moscou dans
une petite chapelle où l'empereur était
venu paraît-il se recueillir jeu pas si
c'est une légende urbaine mais en tout
cas ce lien historique global entre la
france et la russie fait aussi je pense
que la diplomatie française qui était
mise en place depuis des années des
années
perdure cette tradition diplomatique
goulot mitterrandienne en fait emmanuel
macron l'incarnent et le fait qu'ils
soient président du conseil européen est
présent la république française pour les
russes je pense que ça veut dire aussi
autre chose que si un président du
conseil italien ou ou si un premier
ministre
britannique on se demande ce qui
viendrait faire là d'ailleurs demandé ou
avait un tel entretien c'est pas la même
chose la relation franco-russe avait
quand même historiquement très forte
jean pierre garand vous disiez vois la
magnifique outil d'accueil à votre
opinion en tout cas
emmanuel macron avec voilà pas le
respect qu il se doit en substance enfin
voilà ce que vous disiez m'enfin il
disait hier quand même c'est un
partenaire intéressant
on mettra le temps qu'il faudra pour
pour se parler vous l'avez entendu
également
oui mais même président poutine mais
quand même certaines formes par ailleurs
et c'est bien normal le président
poutine je pense qu'ils ne supportent
pas trop les sanctions qui ont déjà été
prises contre lui et contre surtout
contre la russie et il ne comprend pas
peut-être enfin oui le comprend
peut-être retrouve le finalement
cette position qui est celle de l'union
européenne et celle de la france puisque
la france est et là dessus une meneuse
en quelque sorte à l'encontre de la
russie moi c'est quelque chose qui me
dépasse il voulait la russie la russie
la france comme cela vient d'être dit la
russie la france ont une histoire
commune on a on est en fait très proche
en fait nous avons une civilisation qui
est évidemment très proche souvenez-vous
de gaulle bien sûr qu'il disait que
l'europe s'était de l'atlantique à
l'oural voilà or la position on fait de
la russie quelque vingt pays qui est
quasiment pas un ennemi ce sera un mot
trop fort mais qui est véritablement
rejeté de notre part et c'est évidemment
tout à fait anormal le président
français est lui a été en dessous de
tout malheureusement au niveau
international au mali nous avons perdu
53 soldats et au mali malheureusement
le gouvernement actuel nous a congédié
quasiment et on n'a rien fait le
président macron a pris note si vous
voulez les sous marins australiens 56
milliards donc d'euros nous échappe avec
la vexation où la france n'a pu ça doit
alors évidemment le président macro
le soutien des médias seront sur ce
plateau fabien lainé qu'est ce que vous
répondez à jean pierre jean paul garraud
non mais je pense que l'armateur
diplomatie la caricature et la petite
chose pour venir quand on parle que le
président poutine au sommet d'une table
de 8 mètres de long le plan des
républicains si le désintérêt idées à
ceux qu'on accuse les images il a réussi
toutes ces docteurs le keeper
internationaux de la même façon vladimir
poutine pour des raisons sanitaires y
compris votre ami victor ben si garraud
donc arrêter de dire n'importe quoi en
fin de relais politiques
en plus vous mélangez avec le mali bon
ça déchire c'est pas du tout la même
histoire entre un chien pas de ce sav
tollé cléricature on espère des affaires
sérieuses alors je sais très bien que
vous n'êtes pas pour une europe une
union européenne fédérale qui se prend
en main au niveau diplomatique au niveau
militaire mais c'est l'agenda du
président de la république française je
pense qu'il a été clair devant le
parlement européen donc nous assumons
parfaitement sa tâche à dallas et les
français dans deux mois il y aura des
élections et les français trancheront
donc voyez on est dans un champ tout à
fait démocratique
c'est quand même la russie aujourd'hui
et moi j'aime beaucoup la russie contre
dick très tranquillement mais qui ne
respecte pas le droit international et
dont vous toutes les bonnes raisons pour
pas respecter le droit international
je pense qu'il faut reprendre le
dialogue un dialogue rationnel
raisonnable mais ferme avait là aussi
est alors monsieur gare aux jeux
moureaux lichens ce qu'a dit le
président poutine tu es un interlocuteur
de qualité je t'attends tu nous
prendrons le temps d'un défaut au fond
des choses qui se fait parce qu'on est
sûre même entretien très longtemps si
c'était pas un interlocuteur de qualité
penseriez
donné on avait vraiment la faire cesser
et je crois qu'il ya une chose qu'il
faut bien comprendre dans le tempo du
moment c'est que le prison poutine c'est
son quatrième président de la république
on sait ce qu'il vaut face de lui qu'il
y a un passif notamment due à monsieur
hollande et monsieur macron par exemple
sur l'annulation des commandes des bpc
aimait énormément marqué le président
russe qui avait été choqué par cette
annulation et à l'époque monsieur macron
était secrétaire général adjoint de
l'élysée et je pense que monsieur
poutine est bien informé de cette
histoire est donc de ce fait là il ya
tout ce passif là qu'il faut aussi un
moment donné prendre en compte parce que
lui il en a vu quelques-uns président
français et donc tous passif la haie et
est un élément aussi sans doute
difficile dans la négociation merci en
tout cas tous les quatre on est un petit
peu en retard je sais que vous vouliez
vous exprimer mais ça sera pour la
prochaine fois merci fabien lainé merci
beaucoup alexis poulin et franck
louvrier et c'est la fin de cette
émission vous suivrez évidemment cette
conférence de presse en direct sur les
antennes d'ayrté france avec l'analyse
après cette conférence de presse et nous
on se retrouve demain à 20 heures pour
une nouvelle émission qui s'étend de fin
de soirée à tous
d
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qu'on va spécialement dédicacée
à mon ami bruno
bienvenue dans ces caches bonjour à tous
et bon jour avoue olivier bonjour mira
bonjour stéphane jean olivier bonjour à
la crise financière nous a fait prendre
conscience qu'une banque et bien peut
faire faillite et quand ça se passe ce
sont ces clients qui se retrouve dans la
tourmente alors aujourd'hui en 2022 les
banques vont elles vraiment bien
pouvons-nous avoir confiance en elle
sonne au labrit et à quel point ce
sentiment d'insécurité que nous pouvons
tous avoir est légitime et bref devons
nous avoir peur des banques est celle
question laquelle est olivier vous avez
tenté de répondre aujourd'hui au cours
de cette émission avec notre invité sur
ce plateau l'ancien conseiller en
gestion de patrimoine stéphane dubois
stéphane dubois bienvenu merci d'être
avec nous en tout cas une chose est sûre
eh bien on sait que les banques compte
orange et beaucoup beaucoup d'argent l
année dernière bonne nouvelle pour nous
et bien là pas vraiment puisqu'elle
augmente leurs frais cette année c'est
le terroir cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du côté des banques européennes on
attaque 2022 avec le sourire avec la
banane même 2021 marquée des résultats
exceptionnels plus 62 % par rapport à
2020 selon le cabinet refi nitive leur
niveau de rentabilité aurait même
dépassé celui d'avant pandémie
du coup les banques se sentent pousser
des ailes et les montants mis de côté
pour prévenir d'éventuelles défaillances
il chute de 68% en 2021
bref le secteur bancaire est en pleine
confiance et ça profite à tous enfin
tous tous sauf le client car
parallèlement à ses résultats record les
frais bancaires ont explosé en 2022 les
tarifs de free de comptes de virement en
agence et de retrait dans la zone euro
vont subir leur plus forte hausse
globale depuis cinq ans selon l'étude
annuelle de panne aura banques qui
pointe 1,5 pour cent d'augmentation
contre 0,6 pour cent entre 2020 et 2021
l'association de consommateurs s'est
élevée elle table sur une augmentation
de 2 5% sur deux des trois profils de
consommateurs sur lesquels elle a
travaillé
olivier est ce qu'on peut dire que les
banques sont nos amis auront un petit
peu non ça jamais été nos amis elles
sont pas là pour ça d'ailleurs on leur
demande pas d'être notre ami ça c'est
une première chose la deuxième chose
c'est que dans le tiroir cage de
d'antoine on voit que les banques ont
fait